ah the Magic Kingdom where dreams come
true lawmen get their heart ripped out
and eaten Native American tribes are
executed and hideously disfigured men do
horribly evil thinks truly the happiest
place on earth
reading I thought Pennywise only
operated in Maine quickly the Wild West
is it really was the greatest show on
earth if by Greatest Show you mean one
full of chlamydia and lots of scalping
then yes I guess that's accurate Johnny
Depp wears a lot of makeup and something
ridiculous on his head in a movie cliche
not only is this movie roughly six hours
long it's also about 63% footage of
railroad porn there was clearly a fierce
competition for the role of grimy
mustachioed duster wearing deputy number
three so the director just cast everyone
who auditioned Jesus I hope army hammers
character is not on his way to a village
for a torrid summer romance with a
questionably age young man that's some
how critically acclaimed there been so
many storylines crammed into the first
12 minutes of this movie that I'm
genuinely wondering if I'm supposed to
be caring about any of them and what do
you think of our endeavor looks to me
like just a lot a man digging the desert
oddly enough men digging for two and a
half hours would have been just as
entertaining as the final product of
this movie that's right boss it's not
that the Lone Ranger is ineligible for a
gritty reboot especially since it's been
a long time since the original series
but when Gore Verbinski imagined gritty
he literally meant urine-stained and
under a thick coat of mud the future how
the hell did the Cavendish gang know
exactly where John was standing form
outside the door damn it this movie's so
concerned with the way it looks and has
no idea how to actually movie lord crazy
they do got a lot to talk about
if butch was gonna kill Tonto in the
previous scene and one can assume was
planning on doing the same to John then
why is he now chaining them up instead
of shooting them should be slowing down
but now Cavendish just escaped a few
seconds ago riding off into the desert
which is clearly viewable from this
station so how did the deputies not see
any of it
ha ha funny gag but if Tonto were clever
enough to free himself from the floor
restraints he would definitely know that
he's attached to Jo also what the was
tantos plan they're going like 80 miles
an hour
he was just gonna tuck and roll great
job doing that plan that we didn't
discuss in the slightest also how did
they even know this is a bad guy didn't
the rest of the crew ride away with
butch going somewhere yes no no yes no
yes I could say this really at any point
in the run time but mu B has time for
this honestly if you told me this was
b-roll from one of the Pirates movies I
totally believe you
so not one of the lawmen are gonna
picked up this obvious criminal from the
Cavendish gang that's completely
incapacitated I know they're going after
butch but they've got a whole posse they
could use
hey look it's Johnny Depp's career
considering John and Tonto just survived
this even if that train hits them
they'll probably just stub it too great
I have to take you in the hell is up
with armies accent in this movie is he
trying to affect a texan dialect is he
just trying to sound tough here and a
band is it later does the movie really
good and this whole movie relies heavily
on the inability of characters to see
more than 6 inches ahead of them
whatever you say little brother god damn
it we get it
Dan's been introduced as John's brother
explicitly at least three times already
so this identify as sibling and dialogue
bull is unnecessary and infuriating also
Dan sure lost his huntin boner for
Butchie not only is he not attending to
the several dead and injured people from
the train crash his entire Posse is here
for a pseudo comic moment with John
instead of searching for the convicted
felon that's scheduled for execution the
sexual tension is so obvious that if
butch doesn't kill Dan it definitely
will not asking to be happy I'm happy
I'm happy with the life you provide man
I found some awkward ass timing for this
relationships position heavy
conversation I hereby deputize you a
Texas Ranger does this mean he has to
immediately start doing steroids well
you know because deputies palomero and
Canseco did this is what you start
wearing Indian jewelry dan way my kid
brother became a lawyer those two things
are not related in the least it's a nice
hat by the way
they'd have a bigger one or a wider one
Jesus John might as well have a sign
that says moving target on his back oh
man they cut the shot of the Native
American guy watching this with a single
tear running down his cheek Jesus the
scale and beauty of the scenery is
almost sin removal worthy and I probably
would there weren't two and a half
goddamn hours of it
you shouldn't come back John nice of the
snipers to take a little break and let
the reed boys have a little chat before
Dan crooks they damn sure on what takes
something man man Disney really knows
how to pull out on your heartstrings
how'd you get out of jail anyway
so if we establish Tonto is an
unreliable narrator yet and if so why
are we spending another two hours
watching this store but he's the Lone
Ranger
hiyo quite a half-wit wet brain that's
racist it takes over 45 minutes for a
movie to finally declare itself so if
the spirit animal had showed up without
Tonto there to put together his
reincarnation potion how would John have
survived yet another instance where a
character can't see more than six inches
in front of them I'm just gonna add 20
more sins for this occurrence so I don't
to keep bringing it and my blood
pressure up also the shear in
practicality of getting John up here is
about as high as the sheer beauty of the
scenery in fine tracer you find the man
who killed your brother good thing
Collins gave John the paper
advertisement for rets because otherwise
the movie would be over and oh wait the
movie could be over in Collins eyes cut
by the bullets that killed him and the
mask was cut up I taught those hobby
scissors that he keeps on him at all
times just for situations like this good
thing that was a shower and rankling are
close to where Tonto and John were
camping we interrupt this Lone Ranger to
bring you gore Verbinski's move on Rouge
wait Daniel Plainview is here or is that
bill the butcher I always get my DDL
expanded universe is confused mom is
cold he is no longer God about the
singing parrot is me here's one of the
big problems of the movie where they
expect you to remember a character by
name that was last seen about 30 minutes
ago and barely introduced not to mention
it's been almost an hour and John hasn't
blown Rangers once I want to touch navi
babe you are here awesome we finally get
that Sweeney Todd reunion that nobody
asked for word Comanche violated the
treaty they've been raiding settlements
up and down the river because we
definitely needed another storyline in
this fucking slog here of cats Johnny
Depp wears a lot of makeup and something
ridiculous on his head in a movie cliche
man I believe I've located your cat but
he was already and she'd already told
him and Tonto even god this movie stunk
let's call it an act yeah you can call
it whatever you want doesn't make it any
less daytime somehow The Lone Ranger has
more unnecessary jump scares than a
cheap horror movie go around back or you
could just continue this extremely easy
frontal assault on the barn that's
currently on fire Jesus
this movie goddamn John I thought you
were super interested in finding Rebecca
and Danny you definitely heard her
scream so she's close maybe you could
try calling her by her name or something
you're lost aren't you train tracks I
know I joke sometimes about the notes
and the margins of the screenplay making
it into the final script but I would not
be surprised if this is seriously the
case here many moons ago a boy found him
in the desert
flashback within a flashback and now
what Tonto even be privy to this
flashback if he's not even in the
content also this movie has more
montages and flashbacks than rocky 4 and
it's changed for a G pocket watch they
will show dem where the river begins but
Tonto lived in a pretty sizeable village
you're telling me none of the elders got
involved in these conversations with
these obvious outsiders they wanted to
keep the princes secret so they could
one day return these were two men armed
with two guns how did they take out the
entire fucking village by themselves
this implies that they killed a bird
like they used one of their extremely
valuable bullets to take out the bird
and he made a vow when he found these
two men he would drain their bird into
the soil of his ancestors he'll just let
one of them topple off of a bridge while
on a runaway train but it'll be a really
cool-looking crash my name come up
actually it did and it made Tonto out to
be a very sympathetic figure that the
Comanche should have no problem with so
why is he buried here with John the
United States Army finally someone will
listen Maurice if there's anything I've
learned from watching this movie it's
that Army definitely doesn't listen to
reason also I cannot for the life of me
figure out what kind of character John
is bumbling fool confident lawmen
educated buffoon family man seems like
that changes in every scene silver ex
machina this works also this is
incredibly obvious but why they couldn't
they climb out by themselves their hands
and feet aren't even bound it's not like
they're in concrete it's basically like
that time I buried my dad's torso at the
beach going Kemosabe to find Rebecca and
Danny oh yeah I remember them of course
you don't because the movie wanted to
distract you with some backstory in a
silly visual it is a good day to die
same to you wait what he's really
planning on leaving him there to die he
wanted to bring in the man that brutally
murdered his brother to get a fair trial
but he's just gonna leave Tonto to rot
yeah but no to get into this position
John and Tonto would have had to enter
through the mine where dozens of people
were watching and there was a whole crew
of my workers in the cave too I know
these assholes are dumb assholes but did
they
really expect this to work had a nice
smile man Fichtner tested that pg-13
rating as much as he could this is the
creepiest kid-friendly film villain
since Claude Frollo now when did almost
die
there's no such thing as a win bingo oh
my god just don't kill him already they
already know there's a bigger big bad
out there I haven't tried you have
nothing
man it seems like it's pretty early to
already have a protagonist fight amongst
themselves before the climax of the
movie cliche but here we are
go back to your child white coward I do
not need you he really doesn't at this
point Tonto I wanted to kill the kind of
Butch back on the train so why was he
even trying to get John to do it when he
had the chance
dream that this character was originally
cast as Bill Cosby stupid right now
Johnny Depp just couldn't resist
resurrecting some dialogue from dead man
and then then they which Cavendish is
working with Cole asked no one who has
ever seen a film the director said let's
have your character come in eating an
apple because even though this train car
is full of assholes we want you to stand
out the shot of a train plowing through
a cart full of incredibly valuable
silver is just a perfect metaphor for
the way this movie treated its budget
out of this Tonto continued to get into
these caves without anyone noticing and
I know he's in disguise now but you can
walk in there with one I'm not even
joking this firing squad sequence has
taken so long that I think they had to
replace a few members due to fatigue
whoa pump the brakes there Barry I
thought everyone in this cast committed
to giving exactly 58% total effort what
are you do classic not answering the
question I would say they survived this
but at this point I think John and Tonto
are honorary minions I'm just gonna add
10 sins for all the impossible surviving
you missed something where'd you get the
explosives annoying kid will be great at
cinema since bring the girl butch
cavendish is such a legendary wounded
criminal then how is he able to walk
through this crowd freely the town was
just ready and eager to hang this mother
for like a few days ago what you got
makes them read boys so hot under the
collar
anyway maybe I have tasted fine dad of
course the bad guy gets all rapey by the
end of the movie couldn't let any
cliches go untouched this guy would
definitely be fine by Jerry Jones in
I just said go boost a prosthetic port
okay I know this is probably hyperbole
as told by the bull narrator but in the
context of the story John's been a total
fuck-up so how the did he suddenly
become so competent and where in the
hell did he learn to fuckin lasso what I
like most about this movie is how meaty
the female roles are truly an
inspiration for future generations wait
the sink counter didn't realize I was
being sarcastic I guess it's also
stopped paying attention so give that
sin back and send it two more times that
Ranger I mean have you told him at all
you had the firing squad lined up at the
mine that was lit by fuller and the
dynamite thing and the mountain was
really Butch's idea so fuck off with
your blame shaming asshole the first
train had the pin bolt under the
coupling leaving Tonto to pull some
shenanigans to help detach it
we need to abandon that for the finale
to make this conscious uncoupling easily
accomplished nope little known fact
bullets were only used for shooting out
glass back in the 1800s you know I might
actually consider some of the sequence
fun if it made a lick of sense why the
hell are all these people on the train
they weren't planning on going anywhere
during the celebration considering they
had a stage set up between the two
trains and they were directly facing
each other we'd been here before
and I seem to remember talking too much
which led to my ultimate capture even
though I could have ended it very easily
much like I did with your brother and
all his posse and what was I talking
about again wrong brother only casual
almost incest is extremely casual I'm
sure there's an explanation about why
this train is here and how it hooked up
with the silver cars and what happened
to the other train that was going
backwards and all its cars and how the
passengers survived while fuller and
Cavendish died in that crash
but I guaran-damn-tee you movie isn't
interested in giving it to us time's up
Indian and by time I mean that 30
seconds in which I'll train this gun on
you while standing on this wobbly train
rather than shooting you right now
looking past the whole part about John
conveniently passing at this point being
able to catch an object that small at
the speed how in the did that kid know
that John needed the Silver Bullet was
nice to have a lawman on the side of
progress if John's got a moral issue
with supporting the fat cats on the
railroad why the hell did he even show
up to the fucking ceremony can't stay I
know you do because I sure as don't
John's brother specifically asked him to
take his place in the family and protect
them john loves Rebecca and she loves
him so why can't he do his Lone Ranger
and close by
that's not holding you here anymore it's
mom and Rebecca just loves having these
intensely personal conversations in full
view with the public I guess I should be
heading home yeah probably so since
you've been cooped up but a lonely old
man for several hours with no parental
supervision now go away or I shall a
second time do not touch rock rock
cursed
[Music]
damn we're in a tight spot
guess I cut out the wrong brothers hug
the wrong kid died pretty soon no one
would even know you people were here
what do you mean you people what do you
mean you people must wear mask I'm
Batman
they're gonna put the guns right here
when they are done they're gonna leave
then Tweedledee and Tweedledum can load
them up into your little clown car